you're probably looking for somebody's
approval
um even still yeah maybe
i should think about that maybe somebody
who's no longer with this kind of thing
i don't know i used to call it my dad
and tell him what i was doing he was he
was very excited about engineering and
stuff
you got his approval uh yeah a lot
i was lucky like he he decided i was
smart and unusual as a kid and that was
okay when i was really young
so when i like did poorly in school i
was dyslexic i didn't read until i was
third or fourth grade and they didn't
care my parents were
like oh he'll be fine so
i was lucky that was cool is he still
with us
you miss him sure yeah he had
parkinson's and then cancer his last 10
years were tough
and i killed him killing a man like
that's hard
the mind well it's pretty good um
parkinson's causes slow dementia and uh
the chemotherapy i think accelerated it
but it was like hallucinogenic dementia
so he was
clever and funny and interesting and
was it was pretty unusual do you
remember conversations
uh of course from that time like what do
you have fond memories
of the guy yeah oh yeah yeah anything
come to mind
a friend told me one time i could draw a
computer on the whiteboard faster than
anybody you'd ever met
and i said you should meet my dad like
when i was a kid he'd come home and say
i was driving by this bridge and i was
thinking about it and he pulled out a
piece of paper and he'd draw the whole
bridge
he was a mechanical engineer yeah and he
would just draw the whole thing and then
he would tell me about it and
tell me how you would have changed it
and he had this you know
idea that he could understand and
conceive anything and i i just grew up
with that so that was natural
so if you know like when i interview
people i ask them to draw a picture of
something they did on a whiteboard
and it's really interesting like some
people draw a little box
you know and then they'll say and then
this talks to this and yeah
i'd be like this is frustrating and i
had this other guy come in one time he
says
well i designed a floating point in this
chip but i'd really like to tell you how
the whole thing works and then tell you
how the floating point works inside of
it do you mind if i do that you covered
two white boards and yeah like 30
minutes
and i hired him like yeah he was great
this craftsman i mean that's the
craftsmanship to that
yeah but also the the mental agility to
understand the whole thing
right put the pieces in contacts you
know you know
real view of the balance of how the
design worked
because if you don't understand it
properly when you start to draw
it you'll fill up half the white board
with like a little piece of it and
you know like your ability to lay it out
in an understandable way it takes a lot
of understanding so
and be able to zoom into the detail and
then zoom out to the zoom
really fast what about the impossible
thing you see your dad
believed that uh you could do anything
that's a weird feature for a craftsman
yeah
it seems that that uh echoes in your own
behavior
like that's that's the well it's not
that anybody can do anything right now
right it's that if you work at it you
can get better at it
and there might not be a limit
and they did funny things like like he
always wanted to play piano so at the
end of his life he started playing the
piano
when he had parkinson's and he was
terrible
but he thought if he really worked out
in this life maybe the next life he'd be
better at it
he might be onto something yeah
he enjoyed doing it yeah so that's
pretty funny
you